hepplestone my name is Samuel Leeds I'm
a property investor and I make a lot of
money in property I've been investing in
property now for over ten years
I've also trained tens of thousands of
people to invest in property and I'm
gonna in this video do something I've
never done before
which is I'm gonna summarize everything
I know about property I'm gonna
summarize and give you the top seven
property investment strategies in this
video alone so stay tuned
enjoy take notes because when I first
started out in property I've heard all
these perms banded around all these
different strategies and I was
completely lost so hopefully this will
save you a lot of time and you'll
understand what the basic property
investment strategies are so number one
is basic buy-to-let property investment
so buy-to-let is when you buy a house
and then you rent it out so that is all
it means so if you hear someone saying
oh I'm the buying to let investor or I'm
the buy to let landlord it just means
they buy houses and rent them out it's
very very basic although most people do
it wrong because most people buy their
own house first pay off the mortgage
then they buy a second home they really
like in the perfect area and they think
I could move in it myself one day and
then they rent it out and it doesn't
give a very good return on investment so
what I teach people to do is to buy low
and rent high which means that you're
getting a better return on investment
that's buy-to-let
it's a very very good powerful strategy
the second strategy that I teach is
something called hm
Oh hm o stands for house on multiple
occupation and what that means is that
means when you rent a house out just
like buy-to-let but instead of renting
out to a family home or to just an
individual you rent it out room by room
that's why it's called house on multiple
occupancy because you've got multiple
people living in the same property and
they tend to share communal areas they
share a kitchen sometimes they might
even share bathrooms and you're just in
what you're doing when you do that is
you're massively increase your monthly
cash flow because instead of getting
rent from one family you're now getting
rent from four five six different people
in the house that's hey CH mo if you're
going to do that you need to make sure
that you buy in the right location and
also if it's a big hm
you might need to have to get HMO
license the third strategy that I teach
which I've done also very successfully
over the years is something called
serviced accommodation now serviced
accommodation it's kind of like hotels a
hotel when you move into a hotel you
don't move in and move in for good you
stay there for a short amount of time so
you pay maybe a hundred pound one
hundred and fifty pounds for one night
which is a lot of money so service
accommodation is when you rent house out
your house but instead of renting it out
as a HMO or just as an or to a normal
standard family you rent it out on very
short let's so you rent it out almost
like a hotel you don't have staff you
systemize it you put a key safe outside
you list it on air B&B you list it on
booking.com
and what happens is when people come and
go they might stay there one night five
nights someone wants their week you get
way more rent you can double triple even
quadruple your rent and your cash flow
by renting it out as serviced
accommodation it's a very very very
profitable strategy some things that not
only have I done very successfully but
I've also had hundreds and hundreds of
students doing successfully as well
though fourth strategy is this is a
little bit creative now this is called
rent to rent now you may have heard
about rent to rent and not know exactly
what it is let me summarize rent to rent
rental when it rent is when you rent a
property you don't buy it you rent it
and then you we rent it anybody thinking
isn't that subletting is that even legal
it is legal when you do it under the
correct contract you do this under a
management agreement now Warren Buffett
says don't worry about owning everything
worry about controlling everything a lot
of big companies that are actually own
their stock uberta own their taxis air
B&B down in their hotels Amazon don't
own a lot of their stock so what went to
rent is is it's when you rent properties
you control properties you pay the
landlord a monthly rent but then you
convert it into what into a hmm
or into a serviced accommodation unit
and you push the rent up and then the
profit the difference you keep each
month the great thing about this
strategy you don't need to have a lot of
money to get started that is the rent
to rent strategy number five is lease
option agreement or purchase lease
option agreements purchase lease option
agreements are a little bit like rent to
rents but where you rent a property but
you have the option to buy it down the
line so it's like rent to buy type
scheme now the reason the lease option
agreement are very popular within
property investors and the reason
they're very powerful and can be very
profitable is because if you're buying a
property now but paying for it later if
you're setting the price now what
happens to property prices over time
they tend to go up so if you buy the
right property at the right time and you
buy it now on a lease option agreement
but with the option to buy it later
maybe three five seven years time not
only are you benefiting from the monthly
cash flow from the lease option
agreement but you're also benefitting
from the capital appreciation of the
property so lease option agreements are
very powerful profitable investment
strategies where you get the rent and
the capital appreciation and you don't
need to start with any money or
certainly not much money at all to get
started to secure a lease option
agreement and pay one pound minimum
option fee and solicitor fees and that's
about it so it's a very attractive
strategy number six is buy refurbish we
finance rent we call that the burst
strategy or and what that is it's when
you buy a house you push the value up
and then instead of selling it you might
see some property investors saying that
they're buying and selling properties
and well that's not bad you can buy a
house you can do it up and you can sell
it the problem with that is you're gonna
have to pay tax and once you've sold it
you've made a little bit of money but
you're gonna have to pay tax on and then
you've got no property because you've
sold it whereas if you buy a house and
refurbish it and push the value up and
then refinance it
what you're doing is you're pulling out
your money back your being left with a
property which is going to give you cash
flow and when you refinance the property
even if you buy a house and then it goes
up in value and you refinance it the
money that you pull out you don't have
to pay any tax on that because that is
technically debt so you can use that if
the property has gone up over the years
you can use that to buy more houses or
if you buy a property and then you reef
refurb it and refinance it straight away
you can you can use the refinance money
to pay back any money that you paid for
the property in the first place so it's
a way of whether you've got a small
amount of money you can recycle your
cash again again and again now this
strategy again is something that I've
used to build up most of my property
portfolio and even if you haven't got
any money to start with you can borrow
other people's money you can joint
venture with other people if you can
find the right kind of deals the right
kind of deals that you can push the
value up by refurbishing them then you
can use the buy refurbish refinance rent
strategy and lastly number seven is deal
packaging now deal packaging or deal
sourcing or deal selling it's all the
same thing it's when you haven't got the
money or the inclination to actually be
a property investor yourself but you do
have the time maybe you have the
knowledge so what you do is you find
property investments really good deals
and then you package them up and you
sell them to who to other property
investors now the average property that
you package and sell assuming is a
decent property of course will sell
between two to five thousand pounds now
you might think why would anybody pay
you two to five thousand pounds to go
and find a property that they could have
found themselves and the answer is maybe
they couldn't have found it himself
maybe they're really busy or maybe you
have negotiated a really good price if
you've knocked 20 grand off the price is
someone going to pay you two thousand
pounds for that work that you've done
for that great negotiation and the
answer is probably yes so as a deal
packager you only have to find one deal
and sell it a month
I mean most people in jobs they've got
like 10 or 15 things every day that I
have to do if you just said I'm going to
be a deal packager and I'm gonna find
and sell one deal a month that would
replace the average salary I think
everyone should be a deal sorcerer
because even if you're a property
investor and you've got money you're
probably going to find properties along
the way that don't really work for your
strategy but they are good why not just
pass them on to an investor in charge of
fee so those are the seven best property
investment strategies in my opinion I've
been doing them all successfully now for
years and years I've trained tens of
thousands of people through the same if
you would like to learn more then please
do subscribe to this youtube channel
turn the notification bell on if you
found this video helpful smash the like
button but what I really want you to do
is this I'm going to be doing some more
videos on YouTube giving lots and lots
of content around what I've done in
property and helping you do the same so
I wanna know out of those seven
strategies which one tickles your fancy
the most which one are you most excited
about I want you to comment below which
strategy you most excited about because
what I'm gonna do is whichever strategy
gets the most comments in the comment
box is the strategy that I'm going to
spend most time doing my videos on so
comment your favorite strategy below and
then I will spend time doing YouTube
videos on that so comment below because
I need to know what you think so
whichever one gets the most comments
I'll do so are the seven strategies
which one is your favorite comment below
also I do do advanced property
investment training if you'd like to
become a student of mine and you'd like
to learn more and go really into depth
on some of these strategies I am gonna
be running some on line training I'm
gonna be doing this in in form of a
webinar if you would like to have access
to a free advanced property training
with myself then probably the best thing
to do is to subscribe to our newsletter
and you'll be getting regular updates on
any training that's coming or any free
webinars and you can do that in the
description below there be a little link
where you can put your name and your
email and you will be the first to hear
when I'm running some free advanced
online training so put your email
details in the link whatever you
interested in that
if not just subscribe to this channel
smash the like comment below thank you
so much for watching I'll see you next
time